I saw a photo not long ago when I and I
thought we should talk about it because
it's a it's a fantastic image it is you
with Sir Ian McKellen and you're
obviously I think this is when you first
met know your old friends your old
friends we've known each other a long
time and you you guys went in for a kiss
on the lips in front of all the press on
a red carpet on a red that's on a red
carpet yeah I knew what I was doing it
took him by surprise Sir Ian a little by
surprise it was the it was the world
premiere of his movie mr. Holmes which
is wonderful yes
yeah yeah Oscar nomination yes yes and
well we are very good friends and quite
intimate friends can I use that word on
the show how dare you use the word
intimate no you are old friends but
that's that's quite you initiated this
this this this kiss I did yeah because
it seemed appropriate and that is how we
greet one another or say goodbye but Ian
isn't the only one I don't want you to
think I am a one-man guy no or you can
only kiss other sirs yeah is it only
nights that can kiss you receive your
own Kingsley are you guys making out I
mean
yeah yeah I think who would I go for it
if I could I think I think I go for such
Sean Sean Connery yeah yeah you're right
maybe a bit of tongue but you say this
is quite this is this is something you
do this is something that you're
comfortable doing entirely yeah well yes
yeah but I don't do it with strangers
you want to try it out is that what you
[Applause]
I was not I was not going for that or
the same you're not you were looking at
me in a way that I regret does this look
appetizing to you right now
totally
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that was fantastic
you're an incredible tell me why it was
fantastic going i felt passion yeah you
you went right i mean you're an iconic
actor you're a great man you can we
kissed and I just I felt that you
suddenly accepted me as your better did
you feel he is importing did you feel a
connection and I'm not just talking
about a physical did you feel an
emotional connection I did good why is
it unacceptable for a heterosexual men
to kiss each other on the loose says
it's unacceptable I say it should be a
commonplace if you say it it will happen
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please